-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
Let's get to the news.
The 73rd annual
Primetime Emmy Awards
were hosted last night
by Cedric the Entertainer,
with an assist
from Rita the Rapper.
Around 400 people attended the
so-called Justice for J6 rally
over the weekend,
held at the Capitol.
Well, it's not as many
as they hoped for,
but that's still
a lot of reporters.
During a lecture last week,
Supreme Court Justice Clarence
Thomas said
that the court had its flaws
and compared it
to a "car with three wheels."
Well, you know what you do
to a car with three wheels.
Re-tire it.
[ Laughter ]
Do you follow what I'm saying,
Clarence Thomas?
You retire it.
[ Light laughter ]
Mike Scollins liked it so much,
he wanted me to say
the punch line twice.
[ Laughter ]
He thought that maybe
the standing ovation...
[ Laughter ]
I would say it
over the standing ovation.
The House of Representatives
returned Tuesday
from its August recess.
Oh, good.
Just in time for October.
in a new interview,
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden said
that their German shepherd
Major's habit
of biting Secret Service agents
has caused her
and President Biden
to delay bringing a cat
into the White House,
because as much as it hurts
to get bitten,
it hurts even more
to be ignored.
New York Mayor Bill de Blasio's
press secretary
announced yesterday that he will
step down next month
to open
a political consulting firm,
which will teach
aspiring politicians,
I guess, what not to do?
Customs officials said recently
that they have intercepted
thousands of packages
of fake coronavirus
vaccine cards from China.
And you can tell they're fake
because they fit in your wallet.
Tickets went on sale last week
for an immersive experience
based on the Netflix show
"Bridgerton."
And as a reminder,
the first three rows
are in the splash zone.
[ Laughter ]
Ali.
Take it up with Ali.
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday was
National Wife Appreciation Day,
and Rudy Giuliani
got his a card.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, brewer Sam Adams
is releasing
a new limited-edition beer that
contains 28% alcohol by volume.
Said Boston residents, "Aw,
Christ, not another light beer."
And that was the monologue,
everybody.